تغييرات جذريه عصفت بمجلس الامن القومي
تمثلت باستبدال رئيسه علي شمخاني الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي عين علي اكبر احمد
يان رئيسا للمجلس خلفا لشمخان الذي شغل
المنصب لعشر سنوات احمد يان امين المجلس
الجديد تولى رئاسه المركز الاستراتيجي
الحرس الثوري منذ عام 2006 ويعد احد
الاعضاء الفاعلين في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه
النظام بالاضافه الى تسلمه مناصب قياديه
عده في الحرس قرار تعيين احمد يان يعقب
تاكيد مرشد ايراني ضروره التحاليل
بالمرونه في السياسه الخارجيه كلما لزم
الامر لتجاوز اي عقبات يذكر ان تعيين احمد
ياتي بعد تواتر انباء عن استقاله شامخاني
الذي انتقد كثيرا مؤخرا جراء قضيه علي
اكبر احد المقربين منه هو المدام بالتجسس
لصالح بريطانيا بالاضافه لتراسه مجلس
الامن القومي منذ عام 2013 شغل شمخاني
ايضا منصب وزير الدفاع في عهد محمد خاتمي
ولعب دورا كبيرا في الاتفاق مع السعوديه
بواسطه صينيه
علي اكبر احمد يان الامين العام الجديد
للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني كان
قائدا للقوات البحريه للحرس الثوري
الايراني من عام
1997 الى عام 2000 تراس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للحرس الثوري الايراني بين عامي
2006 تراس المركز الاستراتيجي للحرس
الثوري الايراني منذ عام 2006 ويعد عضوا
بارزا في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات